hi i'm ron bailey for recent television
and we have Matt Ridley the author of
the fabulous new book the rational
optimist how prosperity evolves we're
going to be talking about that lovely to
see you Ron
so tell us quickly what is the basic 25
word elevator speech version of the book
things are getting better human life
standard human living standards are
improving in extrordinary ways all the
time and have been for a long time and
that's because of a an evolving
spontaneous order in society that's
coming about through freedom free
exchange and and specialization and it's
it's where that process comes from and
why it's happening to our species when
it doesn't happen to others that I'm
interested in so as I understand it the
simple way to describe the book is you
say ideas have sex what do you mean by
that what I mean by that is that for
biological evolution to work you have to
have sexual reproduction because that
brings together genetic mutations from
different individuals and brings them on
with the same team as it were now for
cultural evolution to get going you've
got to have exchange between different
individuals because otherwise one tribe
might invent one tool and another tribe
might invent the other and they're gonna
go to war and whoever has the best tool
wins and the other tool goes extinct but
if you want that's it if you want both
tools and you want to combine the tools
then there's got to be exchange between
groups and that was actually
surprisingly hard thing for animals to
invent I reckon and it was us that did
it first properly around 100,000 years
ago and it was as if ideas started
having sex and that meant a ramping up
of continually exponentially improving
prosperity for the human species but it
took a long time as you say started
100,000 years ago and for some reason
rather it sped up quite considerably in
the last 200 what happened in that part
yeah well in the first hundred thousand
years it seems to be or that it comes
and goes and it seems to be to do with
population density and then for
thousands of years everything that you
get horrible things that set it back
like Emperor's and you know Wars and
basically predators you know there's
always a tendency of human beings to to
plunder each other and that can set the
whole process back what seems to have
happened around 1800
there are lots of different versions of
this I mean a lot of people say that for
that ideas started meeting each other
much better through the medium of
science and that kind of thing I don't
myself think that I think it's all about
fossil fuels ie that when we started
getting really cheap sources of energy
we could amplify the work we do and the
secret of modern society and the secret
of prosperity is that we're working for
each other each of us is working for
each other so a feature must amplifies
our work with a huge dose of fossil fuel
energy then we can do all the more for
each other so we can make each other
more prosperous and so I think that the
reason it takes off around 1800 and the
rate of growth of the world suddenly
gets a lot faster then and doesn't have
so many setbacks that there are some in
individual countries is because of
fossil fuels nice you're still an energy
determinist so well you've done your
best to dissuade me over the years and
maybe you'll succeed one day but not yet
but one of the ways when you say you're
working we work for each other you have
a wonderful analogy about the number of
people it took to prepare the Sun King
the king of Francis meals and you
compare that to what today how does that
work thank you yeah I think the king
louis xiv of france had 498 people to
prepare his dinner every night
it's allegedly that's what I've read but
you and I have 498 people to prepare our
lunch today by which I mean that within
10 miles of here there are at least 498
restaurants that you or I could go to
and each of them is prepared to serve us
with a very nice meal probably with more
exotic ingredients than nuit xiv ever
saw at an hours notice what's the
difference as far as we're concerned
maybe they're not working exclusively
for us but what's the difference why is
it the pessimism cells why is it so
popular why is every the world always
coming to an end this is a question I
find very hard to answer I ident myself
quite understand why pessimism sounds
wise and optimism sounds foolish but
that's true I mean everybody seems to
agree on that and and and maybe it's
just because people are cautious maybe
it's because they're nostalgic they
somehow think that the world was better
before maybe it's because
it's it's it's as if you're almost
superstitious you know you're wanting to
head it off or prepare for it and by the
way that's one of the reasons I use the
phrase rational optimism I don't think
starry-eyed individual everything's fine
optimism is the right way to go what I'm
saying is imagine the possible
improvement that you could achieve and
thereby don't lose sight of the
possibility don't give up on the
possibility of improving the world so
I'm very much not saying everything's
fine I'm saying quite the reverse
there's a lot of things that could get
better still Dennis give up on the
possibility of improving them in this
you have a lot of data showing how
things improve in the last half of the
20th century could you share the some of
that with us yeah my sort of headline
summary is that I worked out that in my
life the average citizen of the planet
is three times richer corrected for
inflation that his lifespan is a third
longer that he's burying one-third as
many of his children which is a terribly
important measure of happiness if you
like and that food per head is up about
a third and the population growth rate
has halved in my lifetime but a lot of
people know that but it's true how do
you see the 21st century we're here
we're at a time of financial crisis now
there's a climate change problem
possibly so what is it for you first
since you're going to look like well my
estimation and you know I'm no better
forecasting the future than anyone else
is that we will have some pretty dire
times as a result of the financial
crisis in the West and they could you
know they could last a long time I don't
know but that on the whole that won't
interrupt the improvement in average
living standards across the globe
because China and India is still
experiencing growth and there's evidence
that Africa is joining in increasingly
Latin America is doing better
etc so large proportion of the planet is
going to see this recession as a local
problem not as a global problem as for
the longer term there will be Wars there
will be drought there will be
earthquakes they'll be volcanoes
there'll be all sorts of horrible things
happened
the human race as it happened in the
20th century and the 20th century was a
pretty bad century from the point of
view of wars and dictatorships and
things like that and yet throughout that
period human living standards inexorably
rose and so that's what I think is going
to happen in the 21st century as for
climate well I think there is a small
problem small possibility of a big
disaster but there is a very large
probability of a moderate change in the
climate which will actually mostly be
beneficial
slightly warmer weather slightly more
moisture in the air will produce
slightly higher crop yields and
relatively little impact on things like
storms and droughts and species range
and so on now I might be wrong and we've
course got to prepare for the outside
possibilities of things being badly
wrong but I don't myself think it is
probable that we will face a bad century
but there is always the problem that you
have identified is that there are groups
of human beings will call them
chieftains priests and thieves I believe
you refer to them as who could possibly
try to who try to interrupt this so how
do we get around those people
well we somehow the the great thing
about societies that have really worked
well you know Hong Kong recently Holland
in the 17th century etc is that they've
somehow placed the incentives in the
right place so it made more sense to go
into sensible commerce in which you
benefited everybody then it did to go
into warfare as a profession so in order
to benefit pretty well nobody except
possibly yourself and so we've somehow
got to make sure that the incentives are
pointing in that direction for people
now I don't think were that worried
about ambitious Emperor's militarily
invading other countries so much at the
moment although you know we're going to
watch that a bit but I do think we're
worried that we should worry about the
degree to which a lot of big government
although it has a role clearly in terms
of holding the ring as a referee in
terms of ensuring free and fair activity
and society can also be a plunderer
big government big corporations can do
that big finance can do that you know
that the predators and the parasites can
come from many different directions and
I think we've just got to always keep an
eye on whether the incentives are
pointing towards them or not would you
call yourself a libertarian I think I
would call myself a libertarian I don't
think I'm a sort of hole up in a forest
in the Rockies and shoot anyone who
comes near kind of libertarian if that's
what the word means but but I I'm
certainly a believer that on the whole
society is a bottom-up phenomenon in
other words people spontaneously produce
social order through free and fair
exchange among themselves the balance of
risk in this world seems to me about too
much top-down control not too little and
I would love to see a little more
attention to letting people free to get
on with their lives well thank you very
much Matt for coming into reason so Matt
really for a reason television and if
you want to hear more of this join us on
the reason Cruz next year thank you very
much
you